looking at where Cyril was at the end of
the season he kind of got everything
handed to him more or less like on a
platter because he got the same Deidra
and all of these things where is he when
we reunited
yeah I mean a lot happened in that
um meeting in the room closet in the
middle of the riot Etc and I mean
I wouldn't say that moment was
necessarily handed out to you
I saw I mean Cyril is an obsessive
possessive
dissociative person
but seeing someone that he feels like
maybe
he's potentially the first person that
understands the type of person who he is
in trouble
goes to find and help her out of that
situation and then they discover that
actually good will it's not like him
potentially in that marketing are they
here to see each other is there
something deeper here can they create a
union they both want the same thing you
know they both want Android
and the massive question mark is
actually for me coming into season two
is like does he move out of his mother's
apartment
does he grow up and both of those things
happen in a really incredible way like
he was a complete adolescent throughout
season one trying to figure out who he
was what he believes
it's not sure on what he believes in but
he's he wavers he has a lot of Shadows
and in season two he gets here's the
thing
continues on the app
Tony doesn't write level
Tony Gilroy doesn't write level he
writes characters that are completely
out of balance and off-kilter and
in a power struggle whether that's
within themselves in their workplace
with another person
and I mean that's the writing that got
me into the show into the first place I
was like this is like this is a like
picture play this is like so meaty and
exciting and potent and
I mean already within a meeting of Dedra
and Cyril you have a complete imbalance
of power in terms of the social
structure and in terms of the work
structure
um
whether there's another imbalance or not
I don't know uh but there's there's
yeah there's
that that that friendship relationship
Union comparing can only be virtuous
yeah let's do that let's do that and
that's just that gets explored in a
really cool way
will Cyril get an actual breakfast
that's more than cereal
oh the memes that is fun he's never
gonna give up what you love right never
give up what you like and you know if it
ain't broke
um the cereal make the cereal may make a
reappearance first zero surreal yes
well thank you thank you very much